the government is the necessary solution
to a problem and that is us lord knows
what we might do without laws but
there's a problem with government that's
us - first of all the name means
something cool it means to set the thing
up firmly in place it's actually like
the word for statue just think of this
particular problem if you're gonna have
more than one person make the law you're
gonna have to have a constitution to
describe how that's done or else you're
gonna have Wars all the time about who
gets to make the law the problem with
government the government is the
solution to a problem right the
necessary solution to a problem and that
is us but there's a problem with
government that's us
- so Madison Road what is government but
the profoundest of all commentaries on
human nature if men were angels no
government would be needed if angels
were to govern men neither internal or
external controls on the government
would be necessary and since it's true
that both the things that needs
protecting and the danger to it is the
same thing then you have to have some
method of both assembling and granting
power and of restraining and power and
our Constitution is the best at that in
all of history and the explanations of
it by the people who wrote it are the
most profound explanations of that kind
in all of human history